وراء اوكرانيا ولم تقبل بتكريس الامر
الواقع معناه عفوا تكريس الامر الواقع هو
تكريس شرع الغاب هو ان يعتدي تعتدي دوله
على دوله اخرى وان تضم اجزاء منها وكان
شيئا لم يكن فذلك ضرب ضرب كبيره للقانون
الدولي الرئيس بايدن اعلن عن حزمه مساعدات
جديده ترفع الى عدد المساعدات منذ بدايه
هذه الازمه الى مليارات الدولارات
وبالتالي فان الرساله هي اننا لن نتوقف
واننا مستعدون للمضي الى ابعد وقت ممكن في
حرب استنزاف توقعها حتى الاوروبيون والغاء
الحلفاء الغربيون في مؤتمر ميونخ الاخير
حول الامن اذن يقولون باننا نتوقع ان يطول
امد النزاع وان حرب استنزاف ستكون في
الموعد وسنكون في الموعد حتى خساره اذا
حتى انسحاب موسكو من كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه فقط من الدومباس ولكن من من
شبه جزيره القرم ايضا وبالتالي هذا رفع
لسقف
المعطيات
ودخول لمنعطف جديد في هذه الحرب راينا في
بدايه الحرب كيف كانت هناك اصوات في
اوروبا تريد ان تدفع الى التفاوض مثلا
رئيس الفرنسي كانت لديه الرئيس الالماني
كانت كان لديهما هذه النظره التي تريد
التقليل من هذه او اختصار زمن هذه الحرب
الان
المعطيات تقول بان الحلفاء سواء في اوروبا
او في الاطلسي مستعدون الى الذهاب حتى
النهايه هناك ايضا رساله الى الراي العام
الغربي هناك استطلاع في الراي اليوم في
صحيفه لوفيغاغو يتحدث عن انقسام داخل
الراي العامه الاوروبي والغربي حول ارسال
اسلحه الى اوكرانيا في ظل من ان
يتسع رقعه النزاع الى حرب عالميه ثالثه في
ظل
الاقتصاد العالمي المترنح من وراء هذه
الحرب في ظل التضخم
وازمه الطاقه الى غير ذلك لكن الرئيس
بايدن عندما ذهب الى كييف معناه نحو
الولايات المتحده مصره على ان تنسحب روسيا
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي احتلتها وان
يتوقف هذا العدوان معناه بان التفاوض ليس
غدا وليس الان وان الولايات المتحده
والحلفاء قرروا ان يذهبوا حتى النهايه حتى
تحرير كل هذه الاراضي الاوكرانيه فاذا
التفاوض ليس الان رساله اخرى يرسلها
الرئيس بايدن ليس فقط الى روسيا ولكن الى
الحلفاء ايضا